last year Game of Thrones set a world
record for the most stunt people on fire
in one shot and it looks like it hurt a
lot
can't Hollywood just use CGI each year
dozens of movies and TV shows feature
scenes where stunt performers are set on
fire it turns out this is often done
with real fire not visual effects fire
and water are some of the hardest things
to create in CGI and stunt performers
bring a unique take to each scene once
you still get from a person that you
won't get from the effects is human
performance and their own take on
something that's done coordinator rowdy
Earlham he's worked on films like
guardians of the galaxy and Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows his latest
project has been the last four seasons
of Game of Thrones sounds easy right
get a few stunt people some fire your
scene will look great turns out even
just a few seconds of fire requires a
lot of work
you're not just setting people on fire
you have to set them on fire safely the
most extreme type of burn is one where
the stunt person is fully engulfed in
flame
but the biggest risk isn't burning their
skin you need to be holding a breath so
you don't breathe in any kind of flame
in order to keep stunt performers safe
Rowley and his team count out loud to
let them know how much time is left
they remain on fire for no more than 15
seconds the danger is disorientation or
if you were to injure yourself or ban
into something you know what you don't
want to do is is breathe in because of a
shock of pain or injury stunt
coordinators try to anticipate and
eliminate anything that could go wrong
or cause an injury
everything is rehearsed multiple times
so everyone knows where to go and what
to do if you do enough of that you
become competent and confidently run a
very controlled set you know we make a
plan and we stick to the plan and we
execute a plan in addition to lots of
rehearsal stunt performers where a ton
of protective gear and their secret
ingredient is a flame retardant material
called SEL gel for Game of Thrones stunt
performers were three layers of
fireproof underwear which is soaked in
zel gel above that is a rain suit to
prevent the gel from being absorbed by
other layers next is a fire suit and a
thin cotton suit any exposed skin is
also coated in zel gel finally their
costume goes on top you are now ready to
be set on fire and rally Earlham is no
stranger to setting people on fire for
season seven of Game of Thrones 20 stunt
performers were set ablaze at a single
time and 73 were lit on fire throughout
the course of the scene each performer
has their own safety partner who helps
them get dressed and extinguishes their
fire for every four safety people there
is an additional safety person that's
more than forty five crew members for
just one stunt
it took weeks of pre-production and
multiple cameras to shoot but the key to
making that scene convincing wasn't the
fire
it was the acting what we wanted to do
is find the humanity of the situation
these are the human moments when you
feel their suffering crafting a scene
that looks realistic while maintaining
strict safety standards isn't easy well
the check the challenging thing is to
make sure that you don't make a mistake
we can get through stuff and make it
really really exciting and dynamic and
not hurt what do you think we've won
when we were planning to do the 20 man
burn it was gonna rain on Monday and I
was like well it's sunny now I know that
okay what do you mean I said well let's
do this afternoon then he was like but
we can't and I was like well why anyway
I don't know